i need five wide receivers  no tight ends no running backs i want  four receiver stack left tweet or you on  the right we're gonna overload the left  side fortune to cover tweeter one on one  and no huddles what i'll call the place  from the line defense will never know  what hit them all right let's go come on  break them  up  three one two three  what's the problem officer  well i'm investigating the death of  frederica bimmel  there's no one here jack  clarice  your name is  oh jack gordon mr gord good um well  frederica used to work for mrs lipman  did you know her  uh-huh  oh wait  was she a great big fat person  i've been working out haven't you  i could tell  i was hoping you'd give me a bath  very very dirty  bye